fellas I'm getting married
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
better
Hollywood has come a calling they want
to make unfinished business into a movie
our Carefree College days on full
display I love it that book caused a lot
of drama get your popcorn ready
but you need a change of scenery so come
with us to Quinn's wedding it's
guaranteed to put a smile on your face
[Applause]
you need to find something you're
passionate about redefine your purpose I
thought you found your purpose with that
perfume commercial always in my playbook
always in my playbook oh wait I'm sorry
I'm sorry
we all make mistakes and you gotta
Liberty consequences I know what it's
like to be a tired overworked exhausted
mom wait don't you have like three
nannies it takes a village
[Applause]
life doesn't always go the way we expect
but if you're lucky we end up where
we're supposed to
[Applause]
we're actually really looking forward to
some has been a lifetime yes we are are
you two gonna have sex what's sex a
really yummy dessert then can I have sex
okay
you know who I want to play me oh
yeah get your coins together brother
[Music]